today on the map will show a young woman
attacks her racist Trump supporting dad
during the eulogy at his funeral also
speaking of trump he officially
announced his presidential campaign
yesterday meanwhile DeSantis finally
responded to Trump's criticisms of him
we'll review all of that plus a teacher
is fired for confessing his racism to
his class but isn't that what the world
crowd wants white people to do and
Ukrainian president zielinski tries to
hoax the United States into a World War
are we done worshiping this guy yet all
of that and more today on the Matt Walsh
show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
well due to a shrinking herd beef prices
are expected to rise another 15 percent
in 2023 today's prices will seem cheap
in just a few months Supply will
continue to become more and more scarce
that's why I subscribe to good ranchers
because grocery store meat prices rise
good ranchers inflation proofs your
grocery bill by locking in your price
for the life of your subscription if
that's not enough to convince you take
advantage of their Black Friday offer
going on right now get two 12 ounce
Black Angus New York strip steaks and
two pasture-raised chicken breasts free
with any order when you use my code
Walsh while you can't control gas prices
or mortgage rates you can avoid meat
inflation with a subscription to good
ranchers so take the savings wherever
you can get them and in order to do that
you got to go to goodrancers.com use
code wall should check out for this
special offer that's goodranchors.com
code walls for two Black Angus New York
strip steaks and two pasture-raised
chicken breasts free with your order
good ranchers American Meat delivered
well Donald Trump announced his
presidency last night as you've probably
heard I thought I'd begin the show with
his address and we will still talk about
it of course but there was another
speech yesterday one with far less
significant political implications but
which reflects the state of our society
in a way that
a few speeches ever have or could and
needless to say not in a good way so in
an as yet unnamed woman and a
self-professed black supremacist quote
unquote recently posted a video to tick
tock of as she says the eulogy that she
gave her father at his funeral
uh the eulogy went viral on Tick Tock
before making its way over to Twitter on
Tuesday and then out into the mainstream
media Outlets who are reporting on it
now which is how the pipeline usually
works now her father apparently died of
liver cancer which is something that I
only know because she also posted tick
tock's joking about her father's cancer
um how and why would you make jokes
about your own father's terminal cancer
what sort of person would do such a
thing well
um this sort of person actually
but Dad please know that what I'm
grateful and highly aware of all that
you've given this family I still don't
miss you when you died I felt like there
was a hole I missed something but it
wasn't you it was the idea of what you
could become
I miss being able to Hope and wish that
one day you turn a corner and see the
world from my perspective I miss the
idea that one day you might help me
fight for the things that matter I
missed my fantasy of you
because when you died it solidified the
fact that she'll never be what you could
have been but only what you are and what
you are is a racist misogynistic
xenophobic trump-loving sister white
male that is all you will ever be to me
and Dad before you tell me to respect
the dead please remember that you
disrespected and disregarded the lives
and death as an entire Humanities of
people with your ideology you told me to
Never back down so I won't you know for
a fact that even against you I'm not
afraid to share my knees you are
everything I Aspire not to be and I
refuse to stand up here and sing the
Praises of a man who was the Paradigm of
white supremacy so I'll take your racist
mindset I'll take your money and I'll
take your advice and I swear to God I
will make this world a better place not
at all because of you but an exact
opposition to you
think
I'll take your money she says and I I
bet you will now it's hard to know who
to despise more the woman spitting on
her own father's grave or the people in
the audience applauding it I suppose we
need not choose one or the other now we
should acknowledge from the outset that
not every person who dies necessarily
deserves to be mourned you don't become
a good person just because you happen to
die some of us have been to funerals
where the eulogies are conspicuously
brief because there isn't much good to
say about the deceased that's just the
reality I mean if you don't if you if
you don't live as a good person then uh
people are not required to pretend
otherwise after you die and if you let's
say abused or neglected your children
then they are under no obligation to
sing your Praises upon your death
yet we can reasonably assume that such
was not the case in this particular
instance she doesn't indict him for
being abusive or neglectful quite the
opposite she actually acknowledges that
he loved and served his family rather
her charge against her father is that he
was a white straight cisgender Trump
supporter
she is half his race but it's the half
she hates and most of all as she makes
clear she hates him for not agreeing
with her in fact her love for him was
predicated on her hope and her
assumption that eventually he would
think exactly as she thinks her love was
conditional which is to say that the
love never existed at all and the
condition is that those she loves must
be perfect mirror reflections of her own
viewpoints
but death tragically interceded before
her father could realize that she was
right about everything and for that she
hates him and can never forgive him
now
if this incident had occurred in a
vacuum you know if it was entirely uh
anomalous
then there might not be much worth
saying about it this woman would simply
be an ungrateful brat with a wicked evil
heart who will not even have the honor
of being insulted at her funeral because
she'll die alone and forgotten and there
will be no one there to insult her in
the first place that is what we might
say and leave it at that if this was a
freak occur in say total departure from
the norm
but it's not
I mean sure yeah it's it's not every day
that we see someone recite demeaning
slam poetry about their own father at
his funeral but um this is still fully
in line with the spirit of the age
in fact there's perhaps no better
manifestation of the spirit of the age
than a biracial woman lecturing her
white dad at his funeral
this is literally what the left wants
it's not an accident
it is rather the direct result of the
cultural revolution that has long since
been completed and which we are now on
the other side of
let us let us count the ways
so there are three ideas for attitudes
that our culture seeks to instill in
everyone but especially in the Young and
all three are manifested in that video
first of course there's narcissism
right everything's about you
and whatever is not about you should be
made to be about you
the first thing you should think when
you encounter any situation is how can I
put myself at the center of it and if
you encounter any resistance in this
effort to put yourself at the center
then you're being oppressed
indeed anyone who lives a life or who
does anything or says anything or thinks
anything that departs from your
preferences has persecuted you
for this woman her father's funeral is
about her because his death is about her
because his life was about her it was
his job to think and behave as she
demanded by failing to do so by failing
to succumb to the force of her gravity
and revolve around her as she insists he
was guilty of an unthinkable crime
right if she is not the center
then she is being erased
either either she is the star of every
film or else she doesn't exist there is
no middle ground
this is the lesson she learned from the
culture from the school system the media
from every institution loud and clear
second there is dehumanization
those who disagree with you who have
opinions that are not your own and
values you object to are not simply
wrong they are sub-human you shouldn't
merely disagree with them you should
despise them they're not worthy of
respect or even life itself this is a
message that I hear every time I visit
my inbox
I'm informed that I'm a you know a
racist xenophobic transphobic Etc and
therefore I should die and my family
should die and whenever I do die I am
told there will be celebration in the
streets I don't doubt it either
see we make a mistake when we assume
that all of this kind of talk is just
sort of meaningless internet trolling
and it might be trolling
but it also reflects what is actually in
the hearts of millions of people
like when you're online and you say your
opinion and you've got uh three dozen
people telling you to kill yourself for
your opinion
it's not well it's not real that's not
that's not the real world no it's it's
real I mean that you're in the world and
these are actual people saying that to
you
because that is indeed how they feel
about you and your opinion
they have been conditioned to think this
way
again we kid ourselves if we tell
ourselves anything about that if you
have views that that oppose their views
then you are automatically a bigot and
if you are a bigot then you are an
inferior life form you're a cockroach a
parasite
she applies this logic even to her own
father which is no surprise given the
third point
the Third
is that the family is an oppressive
patriarchal conspiracy and your parents
and all of your ancestors going back to
the generations are ignorant backwards
Crow Magnum cave dwellers
the left's goal as always is to break
apart not just the nuclear family in the
abstract as a sort of concept
but to dismantle your actual family
it's not the family that is that is
being threatened I mean it is the the
family on a broad societal level but
what you have to understand it's also
your family your actual family
they want to pull your children away
from you
sever the ties That Bind you together
they would like for us all to be
eulogized by our children in this way
that's what the constant campaign of
brainwashing is working towards
and and where it leads ultimately is to
misery of course for everybody involved
because whatever else you might say
about this young woman and you could say
quite a lot about her much of it not fit
to air but one thing you cannot say is
that she's happy
this is a wretched miserable person
trained to reject everything that might
threaten to imbue her life with meaning
and joy
because that's the thing when you
when you want to be the center of the
universe and when you hate everyone who
disagrees with you
and when you hate your own family
and you hate your own bloodline
that's just another way of saying that
you hate yourself you hate your own
existence
you hate existence itself
because you wouldn't exist without any
of that that this is the this is the
nature of of the world
there is in fact only one universe and
you're not at the center of it this is
the only Universe we have
and so if you can't accept that then you
hate existence for what it is
and that's why we must protect our
children from this madness
so that we don't have them dancing on
our Graves once we have passed on and so
that
they can live a better life
than the one that our culture wants to
give them
now let's get to our five headlines
with the rollout of the student loan
forgiveness plan scammers are seizing
the opportunity they're using phishing
scams in the form of email texts and
phone calls asking you to provide
personal information then using that
information to steal your your money and
your identity that's why it's so
important to understand how cyber crime
and identity theft are affecting our
lives every day your personal
information gets exposed so often that
it's dangerously easy for cyber
criminals to steal your identity you can
protect though your identity by using a
LifeLock by Norton LifeLock detects and
alerts you to potential identity threats
you may not spot on your own like loans
taken out in your name or crimes
committed by thieves pretending to be
you if you do become a victim of
identity threat well theft well then the
good news is there's a dedicated U.S
based restoration specialist who will
work with you to fix it nobody can
prevent all identity theft or monitor
all transactions at all businesses but
it's easy to help protect yourself with
LifeLock you can join now and save up to
25 off your first year at lifelock.com
Walsh that's lifelock.com Walsh for 25
percent off
here's one headline I just want to read
to you right from the top this is from
Media Matters this is daily wire host
calls the U.S soccer team treasonous for
using rainbow colors in one of their
crests at the World Cup
um yes I I did guilty's charge this is
not one of those times when they're
taking me out of context I did say that
and uh I said also they should be barred
from re-entry into the country because
they replaced their Crest with a rainbow
flag and I'm not joking at all if you
replace the American flag with a pride
flag and then you seek to represent the
United States that way abroad then you
should have your citizenship revoked
how about this
because I'm a merciful person so I'm not
saying that they have the citizenship
revoked and then they're going to be
like no nomadic Wanderers with no
country to call home I mean I'd be fine
with that but how about this you
automatically become a Canadian if you
go overseas as an American and you're
flying the pride flag rather than the
American flag you lose your American
citizenship but automatically you're
Canadian that's just it's a legal thing
and now you become Canadian they'll take
you
but we don't want you
uh so I just want to clarify that okay
so Trump announced his presidential run
yesterday
as was widely expected
uh
it's it's an interesting strategy I'm
not uh I'm not aware of and I'm not
saying this has never happened before in
in history but certainly in recent
history
um I'm not aware of anyone who's
announced the presidential campaign this
early I mean we're two years out from
the general election we're still like a
year out from when the primaries would
even start
um
and it's it's it's an interesting
strategy uh now you could see why he did
it
you know one one of the there's a few
strategies a few few reasons uh to do
this one is to change the subject
from the midterms and you know the media
talked about what a failure it was for
republicans and everything else so
you're changing the subject uh you're
also you're putting yourself if you're
Trump putting himself at the at the
center of the conversation maybe sucking
up some of the oxygen to dissuade other
Republicans from jumping into the race
because you know by the time somebody
like DeSantis for example would even
think about jumping in that's going to
be months from now and Trump's campaign
will be in full swing and we'll have
been in full swing for months at that
point
would that dissuade DeSantis or somebody
else from jumping it I don't know
um
the disadvantage what you're going to
run up against is that now you have to
maintain the momentum
you know politics is all about timing
it's all about momentum elections are
all about momentum it doesn't you know
once you get to the election it doesn't
even matter it doesn't matter where you
were in the polls even a month ago what
matters is and what people are saying
about you a month ago how they felt
about it's what all the matters is right
now that's that's all that matters
now you want to have built up
a ground game and everything before that
point
but what matters especially these days
what everyone has the memory of a fruit
fly uh what matters is the moment
and so by the time we get to even the
primaries
uh next year it this is all going to be
a distant past no one will even remember
it
so every political campaign is running
up against that
um it's a challenge that everyone that
anyone running for office deals with the
fact that no one can pay attention to
anything for more than five seconds that
could work to your advantage sometimes
if you're going through a scandal or
something like that but uh generally I
think it's a disadvantage especially if
you want to build a coherent
campaign with a long-term strategy
what how will that work on balance for
Trump
um you've got you can you maintain the
momentum
or can you succeed in stopping other
people from jumping in when they do jump
in does it help them or hurt them that
you've already been campaigning for
months before that I don't know we'll
find out we'll go through a couple of
Clips here from Trump speech
and it was good speech I thought you
know I I've I've always said that
there's like
speech Trump and then there's rally
Trump
and this was Speech Trump because rally
it's kind of off the cuff it's off the
top of the head
um and he's just kind of rolling with it
and then there's the speech where he
delivers it's mostly written down and
he's delivering a speech that's uh that
has been written
um
I think the more that he that he does
the more that he sticks with the speech
Trump version the better it is for him I
think because it stays on message
and usually his message is really good
which is why I like for him to stay on
message
so we'll go through a couple points that
he raised
we'll start with this he talks a little
bit about the issue of women's sports
and uh and parental rights
um this is not an issue that was a major
part of this 2016 2016 campaign then
again it was not something Republicans
were talking about in general in 2016.
um will become a bigger part of his
campaign for 2024 we'll see but here's
what he says
we will not let men as an example
participate in women's sports is that
okay
no way no men no men
my people tell me sir that's Politically
Incorrect to say I said that's okay I'll
say it anyway if you don't mind
we've had we've had tremendous
tremendous problems and and you know
it's very unfair to women just very very
unfair we will defend the rights of
parents and we will defend the family as
the center of American Life
but who would think standing up here 10
years ago 15 years ago that a politician
and I don't like to think of myself as a
politician but I guess that's what I am
and I hate that thought but that a
politician would be up saying we will
defend parental rights of course you can
offend to who would think that we even
have to mention this who would think it
even should be a subject to be talked
about we have to defend parental rights
can you believe this
so I guess I should amend I said This is
speech Trump not Rally Trump it's
actually kind of both because it seems
like it's going off of a speech but he's
also riffing off of uh based on what the
speech says I think that's a that's a
good that's a good combo for him
personally
um
he also gets into I thought this was
interesting and this is uh
this one of the one of the things that's
in the headlines after speech where he
talks about drugs the the problem the
the epidemic of drug overdoses
and his solution that he's mentioned
before is we should execute drug dealers
now this is something I don't think
there's any other Republican on the
national stage that
is saying this or would say this
to Trump's credit let's listen to that
we're going to be asking everyone who
sells drugs gets caught selling drugs to
receive the death penalty for their
heinous acts because
it's the only way
we don't need any more Blue Ribbon
committees we don't need I don't like to
say this and I don't even know if the
American public is ready for it and a
lot of my people say please don't say
that sir that's not nice they kill 500
people each on average
and if you don't do this in China when I
was with President XI I said president
do you have a drug problem no no no no
no we don't he looked at me like I
didn't know what I was doing
now one of the one of the problems that
Trump's going to run into is that you've
got you know the death penalty for drug
dealers which is one idea which by the
way I support now I think obviously we
could all agree that if somebody is like
got a high school kid who's
selling weed or something like that no
one's suggesting that we'd have the
death penalty for that I assume what
he's talking about are people who are
bringing Mass amounts of things like
fentanyl into the country
um it is not at all unreasonable to
discuss the death penalty for people
like that
absolutely
I mean you think about how many people
they are killing this is pure poison
that they are bringing into the country
that they're you know selling on the
streets
and killing tens of thousands of people
every year they're poisoning tens of
thousands of people every year
the death toll is
catastrophic
is astronomical
so if we have this idea that well you
can only get the death penalty for
crimes where someone is killed which
even that I don't actually agree with
because I think a death penalty for
things like rape and child molestation
even if nobody's killed in the process
uh would also be more than reasonable it
would be it's what Justice calls for but
when it comes to the the fentanyl
epidemic they are killing people they're
killing tens of thousands of people
and if you want to have any hope
of putting a stop to this
then
you know
uh
these kinds of penalties have to be part
of that strategy
they're not going to accomplish it on
their own but it has to be part of the
strategy
the issue for Trump though is that he's
got you know death penalty for drug
dealers which in my opinion great but
then he also had the first step back
first step act when he was in uh in the
white house which released a bunch of
drug dealers out into the public
you know he was working with Kim
Kardashian to release prisoners
from from prison and out into this onto
the streets
you can't really do both
so you got to decide which is it going
to be
like are you going to be the president
who is calling for the execution of
people who are selling poison on the
streets or are we going to be the the
president who releases them and you know
from prison
seems to me it's got to be one or the
other
um before his speech
before Trump gave his speech earlier in
the day Ron DeSantis who had not
responded publicly to um to Trump's
criticisms of him
was asked about it during a press
conference
and uh
here's what he says
one of the things I've learned like
learned in this job is um uh when you're
do when you're leading when you're
getting getting things done yeah you
take incoming fire that's just the
nature of it I roll out of bed in the
morning I've got corporate media Outlets
that have a spasm just the fact that I'm
getting up in the morning and it's
constantly attacking and this is just
what's happened I don't think any
Governor got attacked more particularly
by corporate media than me over my
four-year term and yet I think what you
what you learn is all that's just noise
and really what matters is are you
leading are you getting in front of
issues Are you delivering results for
people and are you standing up for folks
and if you do that then none of that
stuff matters and and that's what we've
done we focused on results and
Leadership and uh you know at the end of
the day I would just tell people to go
check out the scoreboard from last
Tuesday night
I think it's a good response it's it's
the only response you can really give
because you can't get down into the mud
with with Donald Trump you'll lose I
mean he'll he'll beat you there
so and this is the mistake this is you
go back to the and we live in a
different world than we did back in the
primaries in 2015. so making these kinds
of analogies only it only takes you so
far but still if you go back there and
you see what happened with most
Republicans is that
at first they tried to ignore Trump
um
and then eventually Trump just didn't
give him an option anymore and so then
they switched courses dramatically I
mean Marco Rubio's classic example this
go from ignoring to switching
dramatically and like diving down into
the mud with him and trying to out Trump
trump and it just it doesn't work you
look ridiculous you look uh inauthentic
and you're not gonna win in that fight
so I think the only option for DeSantis
at this point is what he just did there
I think it was the right choice is just
to try to kind of stay above The Fray
and he was asked specifically about
Trump but if you listen to that clip was
another smart move if you listen to the
clip you wouldn't even know that that's
what he was responding to because he
doesn't even say Trump in the in the
answer it gives a broad General answer
and then says I'm focused on governing
in Florida that's all I care about I
think that's what he has to do
especially now when he's not
when he hasn't even come close to
announcing his candidacy
for the president
um if he ever does announce that
now can he maintain that
if he does jump into the primaries and
there's an actual primary battle between
these two when they both have declared
officially
can he maintain that kind of answer the
entire way through I'm not sure but for
right now it's it's definitely the best
way
a little bit more politics Mitch
McConnell was asked to give his own
autopsy of the Republican Party post-mid
terms
and here's what he said
here are the criticisms from Senator
Scott and others who agree with them is
that your decision not to have an agenda
to run on opened up Republican
candidates to attacks that they didn't
really stand for anything what is the
response to the criticism that you are
partially responding to every one of our
candidates knew what they were for
expressed it quite clearly
uh it's pretty obvious that all of
you've been writing about it what
happened
we underperformed among Independents and
moderates
because their impression of many of the
people in our party and Leadership roles
is that they're in God's in chaos
negativity
excessive attacks
and it's it's frightened uh independent
and moderate Republican voters and we
saw that which is why you all recall I
never predicted a red wave we never saw
that in any of our polling in the states
that we were counting on
to win there wasn't a way
we had national issue set that was
favorable
but as a result of our own the
perception many of them had that we were
not
dealing with issues in a responsible way
and we were spending too much time on
negativity and
attacks and chaos they were frightened
and so they pulled back
they were frightened well this is the
great thing about the Republican
establishment that there are no
surprises with them you know you know
exactly what they're going to say that's
either the great thing or the terrible
thing you decide but this was no
surprise we lost because too negative
too extreme too chaotic he says we
frighten the poor helpless hapless
moderate voters
now it is true that and I've been saying
this for the last week if your message
is only negative okay if you're if your
only message is Joe Biden is bad that's
the negative message
then it's not going to resonate you're
going to lose and that was a problem for
republicans in this election
is that um as we've been discussing over
the last week
what on the national level what was the
Republican party's message to the voters
and the only one that Springs to mind
the only consistent message was Joe
Biden's bed which he is and that is a
case you have to make but then you also
have to make a case for why you argue
he's bad here's why I'm good
um
but I don't think that's Mitch
McConnell's only point because the
message from The Establishment has been
clear as always that we need to get away
from the culture War issues you know
stop scaring the independence stop being
divisive McConnell doesn't say that
explicitly here because I think he knows
better than that but he also doesn't
have to
that's that's that's what he's actually
trying to convey
so when he says it was chaotic and
negative that's another way of saying
focused on the culture War focused on
issues that are controversial let's not
talk about that let's get back to uh
whatever tax Cuts Etc
um
and we've heard this a lot I mean and
it's not just from Mitch McConnell I've
also heard this from conservatives who
are not members of the GOP establishment
especially when it comes to abortion
you know there's this uh
consensus that seems to be forming among
a lot of people on the right
including people who I usually agree
with
that
there was too much focus on the pro-life
message in the midterms and that's part
of the reason we lost
which I think is just absolutely absurd
it now yes it's true Democrats dominate
with single liberal women and uh it
stands to reason that a good portion of
them were motivated in part by their
desire to be able to continue killing
babies
fine
but here's here's the point
the problem is not when Republicans are
out there
uh making the pro-life argument
I mean the idea that that Republicans
are too pro-life or are too open about
it and talk about it too much is uh to
someone like myself has been in the
pro-life movement for years it's it's
absurd
if it wasn't so frustrating you'd have
to laugh at it really the Republican
party that's their issue is that they
lean into abortion too much
it's been quite the opposite for decades
now
the problem is not
that you're talking about
abortion or you're making the pro-life
argument
it's it's if there is an issue it's that
you're not making the argument
successfully or competently
okay so right it's it's not enough to
just bring it up
that's that's not going to motivate
voters
you can't you can't get up there and and
simply declare I'm pro-life abortion is
bad and leave it at that
if that's all you're doing then yeah
that's not going to be successful
and all you're doing is uh is lobbing up
you know softballs for the other uh for
the other team to bat over the fence
um if that's all you're doing
but you have to make the argument
successfully
you have to explain why you're pro-life
why it matters
which which is really not a difficult
thing to do but you have to make the
argument which many Republicans don't
now we the left can say all they want
Democrats could say oh they're right
they're out Republicans are at a step
with the American public when it comes
to abortion
well I think most of the American public
they don't know exactly how they feel
about it so if you have any kind of
fully formed view on abortion then
you're already quote unquote out of step
with the public
but one thing I do know that every poll
shows this is that most Americans even
if they're a little bit confused about
the issue and they don't think about it
that much and they don't think very
clearly about it uh most Americans
certainly are not on board with
murdering fully developed infants in the
womb like a second before they're born
most Americans are absolutely not on
board with that because you don't have
to think about abortion very much to
recognize that as
as a as a base evil
yeah fully developed infants
and you're you're murdering them
of course that's disgusting and most
people see it that way
but that's what the Democrat Party
supports
every mainstream Democrat on the
national stage every single one of them
with with maybe the the the most rarest
of exceptions every single one of them
supports abortion up to the moment of
birth and many of them will even tell
you that they support it after birth too
you should be able to communicate that
and if you can't communicate that
and uh back your opponent into a corner
over his support for the for infanticide
then you should be running for office in
the first place
you know if you're into if a republican
candidate is in a debate with a Democrat
and the and the Republican allows the
whole conversation to revolve around the
hard cases the exceptions of the to the
rule the one percent of cases all you
ever want to do is talk about rape
incest life of the mother cases we're
talking about less than one percent of
all cases and if you as a republican
allow the Democrat to make that the
whole conversation
then that's your fault you're
incompetent the issue is not with the
pro-life cause or with our argument on
abortion it's that you are incompetent
because what you should be doing is
flipping it around on them and saying
okay we talked about the one percent of
cases let's talk about the 99 where
abortion is used as a form of birth
control how do you feel about that
how do you feel about a fully developed
infant one second before emerging from
the birth canal does that infant have
the right to life or not yes or no
foreign if you can't figure out how to
flip the script like that on your
opponent then again just don't run for
office
all right I was thinking about doing
this for the daily cancellation today
but it would be uh be a bit redundant as
our potential cancel e has already
canceled himself and um yet there is
something to be learned from his
self-immolation I think he fed himself
into the wood chipper and he has
provided us with an important cautionary
Tale in the process uh and you know and
the moral of the story is don't jump
into a wood chipper really if you needed
that lesson here it is uh literally or
figuratively don't jump into one so CNN
reports a middle school teacher in
Pflugerville Texas has been fired
District officials said on Monday
after video was posted to social media
showing the white teacher tell his
students that his race is the superior
one quote last Friday November 11 the
fluger flugerville ISD officials were
made aware of an inappropriate
conversation at a teacher a teacher at
Bowles Middle School had with students
during an advisory class Pflugerville
Independent School District
superintendent Dr Douglas Killian wrote
in a statement as of Monday morning
November 14th the teacher in question is
no longer employed by Pflugerville ISD
and we are actively looking for a
replacement uh videos of the
conversation question were posted to
social media last week now
from the way that the media is reporting
on on this incident
you might imagine that the teacher went
on a wild unhinged white supremacist
rant
which in some ways it was wild and
unhinged
but I want you to listen to the to the
tone and uh anyway let's listen to that
and then we'll talk about it
I'm ethnocentric which means I think my
race is the superior one
so white is better than all no let me
finish
I think everybody thinks that they're
just not honest about it I'm not racist
though I like all types of comments did
I say I don't like people people so you
said you are what
all right
I've said it enough so you're ready
I don't think I got respect for him no
more bro you know you should have more
respect
now by the way the district has made
counselors available to students who are
traumatized by this uh by this event
somehow I don't think the councils will
be necessary because the students seem
to be more amused by it than dramatized
I mean they're laughing about it and uh
and you could you could tell the teacher
as he's talking like you can see him
realizing as he's talking that he
shouldn't be saying this and uh and you
could see the regret set in and then he
I think he tells one of the students to
put their phone away but it's too late
because he's already on camera he forgot
the student that was sitting right next
to him
here's the point here though
that this teacher is actually doing
exactly what the woke crowd tells him to
do
right this this is this is CRT in action
this is what it is
um
white people are inherently racist
this is what we're told this is what all
the race Hustlers will tell us about
Robin deangelos and and uh ebermax
Kennedy and all the rest of them
uh in fact if you as a white person tell
them that you are not racist they will
tell you no it's racist to say you're
not racist because you are racist and so
what you need to do is confront your
racism and admit to it
uh you have to confront your confront
your racism admit that you're racist If
you deny that you're racist that's only
further confirmation that you are racist
and that's racist in itself white people
are inherently racist black people
cannot be racist because of structural
you know it's racism is Prejudice plus
plus power and blah blah blah
um and and then what they also say is
that we need to start having
conversations
right have conversations about race
and so this teacher
attempted to apply all of that is that
we're gonna have a conversation about
race
and uh I'm I'm gonna admit that I'm
racist because this is this is what
we're supposed to do that's the woke
thing we're all inherently racist
you got one detail wrong though and
maybe if he got in this detail right he
wouldn't have been fired
um but he says well everyone is racist
that's actually that's not what CRT
teaches CRT teaches that only white
people are racist
which is an important distinction for
them not everyone only white people
now we we if you were to play this video
back
rewind it and if he was able to do that
again he probably would just keep his
mouth shut but
um if he could phrase it differently
imagine if he had said everything the
same
he said I'm ethocentric I'm racist but
all white people are all white people
are inherently racist
then I think this becomes a totally
different thing I don't think he gets
fired for that
so he was attempting to do
what the world crowd wants him to do
got the details a little bit wrong
now he's fired
um
but of course even if you've gotten them
right I mean it's uh it's this is this
is this is a thing you're racist either
way it's it's sort of like uh go back to
the Witch Hunt days and uh If you deny
that you're a witch then well that's
what a witch would do you're lying so
you're gonna get executed but if you
admit that you're witch well then you're
a witch so we're gonna execute you for
that
this is the it's the quintessential uh
you know
get woke go broke situation what you
just saw there
all right let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
[Applause]
who's the blame
it's a sweet baby gang
Lisa says I'm showing what is a woman to
my sophomores this week I can wait I
can't wait for our discussion afterwards
I work at a Christian school so I have
the ability to show this video to
students they'll learn to debate and how
to discuss these topics with those who
have differing views thank you for
making this possible
well I'd love to hear that and uh I
think sophomore and people ask me a lot
it should
parents asked me should I let my kids
watch this is appropriate for kids and
you got to make a determination
um for yourself based on what you know
about your kid
but uh you know my kids are
both kids are nine years old they're way
too young I'm they haven't seen the film
I'm not gonna show it to them but once
you get to be a sophomore in high school
uh this is certainly well within the age
range where I think uh it's necessary
and appropriate to show them the film in
a perfect world it wouldn't be because
in a perfect world even as sophomores
they would not have encountered any of
this stuff but being sophomores they
certainly have by then so
um that's where the film comes in okay
Michael says Matt I saw your tweets
about Ukraine it seems hypocritical that
you complain about Ukraine funding while
supporting foreign aid to other
countries
once again you're being inconsistent who
told you I support foreign aid to other
countries I am against all foreign aid
to all countries
uh I've always said that I I don't like
the idea of American tax dollars being
sent to any foreign government's period
if a country can't survive without a
constant influx of American tax dollars
then uh then it doesn't deserve to exist
I mean it's as simple as that for me
you have to be able to stand on your own
two feet as a country at a certain point
and the idea that we've got you know
dozens of countries or more across the
globe that are on the Dole and you're
taking money away from American families
and getting it to foreign governments I
mean what happened to taxation no
taxation without representation we're
not represented by that we have no
control the money is spent
and however it's been it's not
benefiting us directly so I'm against
all of it
uh Jr crash says Matt just tell your
wife that you think of the stuff that
walrus as a type of pillow then she'll
be forced to concede that there's room
for it in your house you don't think you
think I haven't thought of that already
that's been my argument this whole time
it's basically a big glorified pillow
that the whole family can share
you know we can watch a movie together
and we can all be leaning against the
big giant stuffed walrus that's my
vision it's a family bonding
but she's not going for it
um
let's see
Jordan says anyone with a junior high
understanding of biology knows there are
far more than two sexes in nature that
many animals change sex regularly Matt
are you ignorant or do you just get off
on hurting others different than you
when did other animals
come into play here what are you talking
about
okay you say there are other sexes in
nature
uh
that that may be true for some I mean I
think I read an article recently
actually about a a certain species of
microscopic worm that scientists say has
three potential Sexes there's male
female and then hermaphrodite
um
and the hermaphrodite as far as I know
actually have the the functional
reproductive capacity of both sexes it
for this microscopic worm they're also
asexual organisms out there there are
organisms out there that can reproduce
on their own
um all of that is really interesting
Jordan
but they're not human beings we are not
microscopic worms okay we're not
single-celled organisms we're not
amoebas we are human beings
so how does that how do you think
how does the self-identification of a of
a of a human being how is that validated
or legitimized by a microscopic worm or
an amoeba
when you are not that though okay
we're humans you know what there are
also animals in the animal kingdom that
have gills and can breathe underwater
I still wouldn't recommend if you're a
person I wouldn't recommend trying to
swim to the bottom of the ocean without
any scuba gear
there are animals the animal kingdom
with wings
doesn't mean you should jump out of the
you know window 50 stories up
is that if you saw someone about to jump
out of the window 50 stories up and then
and then you saw me trying to stop them
and I said you don't have wings don't do
that would you say little yeah you're a
smart one Matt don't you realize that
there are a lot of animals with wings in
the animal kingdom
yeah I'm aware of that but this is not
one of those animals okay
Candace says uh Matt you always talk
about a different candid system Matt you
always talk about how shopping cart
ditchers are Psychopathic monsters but
what other small infractions indicate
that someone is literally a Nazi I have
one bumper Riders people who ride your
bumper in traffic should be
excommunicated from Earth I could not
disagree more with you Candace I'm
afraid in fact you are the one who
should be excommunicated and banned from
the show obviously because if you're if
you're I don't have this problem with
people riding my bumper do you know why
because I keep up with the speed of
traffic and I'm not going to be in the
fast lane going you know 60 miles an
hour I realize that if you're in the
fast lane on the highway you need to be
going at least 25 miles over the over
the limit at least to justify being in
the fast lane
um so I don't I know I don't have this
issue if you have this issue it means
that you are driving too slow
I'm an Unapologetic bumper writer
because uh because it's just my way of
communicating to you that you need to
speed up or move over
how else am I going to communicate it
so yes there are other seemingly small
infractions that indicate that someone
is literally a Nazi
and driving too slow is one of those
things unfortunately Candace
you are a Nazi and banned from the show
you know something smells over at my
swag Shack something like sweet baby
Spirit that's right fealty to the SPG is
In Bloom this holiday season so come as
you are and get yourself these sweet
baby album tea we actually have that
hang on
oh I don't know what that was uh so here
is the T-shirt
and this is for we are you know
if you don't understand what that's a
reference to then uh you're not a member
of the sweet baby gang uh
Millennia Nostalgia is a big thing and
uh lots of companies are cynically
exploiting it and so we're gonna do the
same um you know why why does everyone
else get the profit off of The Nostalgia
and we don't we're going to also do that
they're only about 500 of these in
existence and we're trying to sell out
so don't wait it's the perfect gift for
yourself and everyone you know because
there's just something in the way they
put my bearded infant self on a t-shirt
that no one can withstand having
I don't think that makes sense that
doesn't no one can withstand having
nobody can stand not having
if they can't withstand having it that
means that they don't want it
anyway
you should want this and you should buy
it head over to my collection over at
dailywire.com shop and get the sweet
baby album t-shirt or any of the other
amazing holiday offerings at the new and
improved daily wire plus shop and get
free shipping for orders over 75 and a
free left of steers tumbler with all
orders over 100 you know here at the
daily wire we're doing everything we can
to loosen the left's grip on culture
we're making movies that challenge woke
Hollywood neighbor narratives
documentaries like what is a woman that
exposed radical gender ideology we're
creating kids content parents can trust
we even sued the government over
unconstitutional mandates it's a lot of
work and there's still a long way to go
but you can help in just two simple
steps One Stop Shaving with your woke
razor two start shaving with Jeremy's
we're building Alternatives and the left
is betting their bottom billion dollars
that you won't use those Alternatives
prove them wrong go to Jeremy's
racers.com get your Founders series
shave kit today Jeremy's razors shut up
and shave now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
well if you pay attention to the news
cycle which is not a hobby that I really
recommend you may have noticed yesterday
that we were on the brink of a nuclear
World War again
a missile hit Poland killing two people
and the immediate assumption by the
media and the social media peanut
gallery was that Russia had launched the
attack
now why would Russia attack Poland I
mean why should we even think that
Russia attacked Poland
well it doesn't matter all we needed to
know is that a bad thing happened
overseas which means that Russia is
responsible and that was certainly
Ukrainian president zielinski's message
who put out a frantic statement calling
for an immediate Global Response to
Russian aggression against Poland this
is what he said yesterday quote terror
is not limited to our national borders
Russian missiles hit Poland to fire
missiles at NATO territory this is a
Russian missile attack on collective
security this is a very significant
escalation we must act I want to say now
to all of our polish brothers and
sisters Ukraine will always support you
Terror will not break free people will
not Break Free People Victory is not
possible when there is no fear Russia is
terrorizing us and everyone it can reach
well that was yesterday here is today
from Reuters quote a missile that hit
Poland was probably astray fired by
Ukraine's air defenses and not a Russian
strike Poland and NATO set on Wednesday
easing Global concern that the war in
Ukraine could spill across the border
NATO's Chief said that Moscow not Kiev
was ultimately to blame for starting the
war in the first place and launching the
attack that triggered Ukraine's defenses
this is not Ukraine's fault Russia Bears
ultimate responsibility as it continues
its illegal war against Ukraine this
according to Nato Secretary General Jen
stoltenberg who told this to reporters
in Brussels so it was Ukraine's fault it
was not Ukraine's fault it was Russia's
fault
God now
a question
um
did zelenski know that it was a
Ukrainian missile but then pretended
otherwise in order to draw Western
governments into a direct conflict with
Russia or did he not know which means
that he was repeating bad Intel without
taking even a moment to verify it ahead
of time
I suspect the former is probably the
case he knew better but the latter isn't
much better because either way
it should be enough to give us
pause to give our government pause
it's reason for careful consideration
before continuing to hail zielinski as a
Messianic figure while also keeping him
on the taxpayer Dole like a like a
international Welfare Queen
but this regime isn't one for careful
consideration which is why we will
respond by uh not by you know blaming
zielinski not by being skeptical of them
but rather by giving him another 40
billion dollars
this from the hill quite quote the White
House on Tuesday asked Congress to
approve 37.7 billion dollars in
additional aid for Ukraine amid Russia's
Invasion a request that comes ahead of
both a government funding deadline and
the expected flipping of the house to
Republican control the by Administration
is requesting that Congress authorized
21.7 billion dollars in defense Aid to
continue providing equipment to Ukraine
and to replenish the Department of
Defense stocks it also is asking for
14.5 billion for direct budget support
to Ukraine critical War Time Investments
and security assistance as well as to
strengthen Global Food security food
security and provide humanitarian
assistance additionally 626 million
would go to providing nuclear security
support for Ukraine and to modernizing
the Strategic petroleum Reserve to
reduce domestic energy costs and to
ensure sustainable access to energy
resources and 900 million dollars would
go to help with health care and support
services to ukrainians
right
our own cities look like third world
refugee camps but we are somehow in a
position to shovel Untold billions of
dollars into the pockets of foreign
governments
you can barely afford to you know put
food on your table or shoes on your
children's feet yet here we are throwing
another 40 billion dollars into the
collection basket for Ukraine
but why I mean that's the question
that's rarely asked and never answered
why exactly are we tying ourselves to
Ukraine why have we been doing this for
months why is it our responsibility to
fund and defend them
how does this serve the interests of
average Americans
well one of the top Ukraine boosters in
Congress representative Alyssa slotkin
appeared on CNN over the weekend and
attempted to answer
that very question here's what you said
when you look at how far Ukraine has
come thanks to the help of the United
States and and allies and I was told by
president zielinski that he really
thanks the American people because he
knows it's taxpayers money and support
from people around the world he's not
silly about this he absolutely knows
what more do you think uh the United
States and NATO needs to do to to to
make them win and Russia lose which is
the stated goal of the U.S
yeah I mean look I I understand I mean
even in my own district there were
people we'd knock on doors and they'd
said look I support Ukraine but you know
how many billions are we going to give
and and how long is that going to be so
that pressure is a real pressure um and
the American people have been generous I
think it's important to recognize that
um but I think we also need to recognize
that what's going on in Ukraine and
Russia is not just like a some Far Away
issue that doesn't affect everyone in
Europe everyone in the United States and
everyone who supports democracy do we
want a world where a neighboring country
can just invade a democracy and claim it
as their own territory should there be a
punishment for that should there be a
price to pay and I think we need to
remain resolved on that and supporting
the ukrainians in what has been a really
incredible run to take back that
territory I think is has been important
but we can't get weak in the knees as
they're having these successes as the
winter sets in so a lot of us are really
talking about this in Congress about
whether you know what more we can do
with anti-aircraft you know a bunch of
weapons to help protect them from the
missile strikes that we saw today just
anything we can and I really reject this
idea that somehow we should just like
give up on Ukraine call it a day and get
to negotiating with Russia you know
that's not real International Affairs
Russia it needs to be they need to pay a
price for this
it's hard for me to explain just how
repulsed I am by every part of that
conversation and by both of the women
involved in it
each sentence uttered is more
infuriating than the last
so let's go through it piece by piece
first we're told
that zelenski is grateful for the
American people and our generosity in
sending so much money directly to him
solinsky is in fact so grateful to us
that he tried to you know hoax us into
another into a World War again that
that's his that's his way of showing
gratitude is to hoax the United States
into a world war that gets millions of
people killed
but all this talk of generosity is
disingenuous at best
American taxpayers have not been
generous to Ukraine we had no choice the
money was taken from us against our will
Thanking us for our generosity is only
it only adds insult to injury it's like
getting a thank you note in the mail
from the guy who stole your car the week
before
that make you feel better or worse
generosity is an act of will it's a
choice
and this is exactly the point we didn't
have a choice if the if the average
American taxpayer was given a choice if
this was put up for a vote if we were
asked how much money we want to send to
the Ukrainian government I'm guessing
that almost all of us would say zero
dollars and zero cents
I know I would I'm all for helping the
needy but foreign governments are not
charity cases they should be expected to
care for themselves
can also insist that we must not give up
on Ukraine
on that I agree you know I can never
give up on Ukraine I can't give up on
Ukraine because Ukraine was never my
concern to begin with
there's nothing to give up on
it's not for me to give up on or not
give up on them Ukraine is not my
country it's not my job to fund it
defend it preserve it or care about it
I have as much concern for Ukraine as
Ukraine has for me which is none
does does Ukraine have any concern for
the United States of America does
zelenski
give the slightest damn about the United
States
he's been trying for months to pull us
into a world war that would get millions
of our kids killed
he doesn't care about us and yet I'm
supposed to care deeply for him
now it's not to say that I don't care
about the Ukrainian people as human
beings I care about all humans I wish
them all well
but the fate of Ukraine as a political
entity as a nation as a government is
not my burden to carry it and it's not
yours either
you know there are 195 countries on this
planet
all of them must struggle in their own
way to survive nobody imagines that
we're responsible for the fate of of
most of the 195. most people in America
couldn't even name the majority of the
other countries on this Earth few of us
could name all of them yet for some
reason out of these 195 it was decided
suddenly several months ago that Ukraine
a country that most of us had spent not
a single moment even thinking about
prior to this year is extremely
important to us and we must be willing
to give give it as much money as it says
it needs even plunge ourselves into a
cataclysmic global war for its sake we
must be willing to send our children off
to die for it if that's what it comes to
we're told
not for any of those other countries but
for Ukraine
why well people are suffering in Ukraine
they're suffering all over the globe
they're suffering in every country
well slotkin gives an answer as to why
Ukraine specifically is our problem
her answer such as it is is that um well
we have to keep Ukraine on the Dole
and even discourage peace agreements
discourage them she doesn't want a peace
agreement
she does not what these Psychopaths they
do not want peace they want the war to
continue and they want us to get
involved in it that's what they want
she just said it explicitly
we have people representing our country
and supposedly our interests and they
are willing to say on the record on
camera that they do not want peace
and why is that well uh because she says
that we need to make Russia pay a price
we have to punish them
Russia must be taught a lesson
these are the same people who release
violent criminals back into our
communities and call it forgiveness
while innocent Americans pay the price
for it yet in Russia's case suddenly
they've become advocates for severe and
violent Justice since what do they give
us about Justice any of these people
since when do they care about that
this is just as it's the right thing
they don't care about that in any other
context
to be clear they want Justice they want
to punish the evil duders in precisely
the situations where it doesn't benefit
anyone in this country to do so
and why must Russia specifically be
punished
I mean there are many countries run by
corrupt regimes who've committed
atrocities
one of the another one is called Ukraine
by the way
should we punish all of them
is it America's job to be a sort of
international Batman rushing to the
scene to punish the bad guys no matter
if the situation concerns us or not
how does the average American family
benefit
from punishing Russia
for making sure that Russia pays a price
how is the average American hurt if
Russia is not punished
how are they helped if they are
I mean if you could explain that to me
you explain how the average American
sitting around their dinner table is
somehow
helped in their own lives
how their own well-being the well-being
of their children is helped somehow in a
direct way
by making Russia pay a price rather than
having peace
if you explain that I'm all ears
but you can nobody can
these are not questions that the Ukraine
boosters in our government can answer or
care to answer because they are not
concerned with the interests of the
average American they do not care
they don't care if we if if you can't
afford to feed your family if you if you
if your children die in an unnecessary
Global nuclear war they don't care about
that either
and they also don't care about Ukraine
by the way
just to be clear
and that is why they are today canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
foreign
[Music]